and they had these tapes that they made
of people walking through new york city
and
what they did was
try to figure out
who these
violent criminals would attack and there
was a couple things the the
i like this one the non-victims
people that the the perpetrators would
look at and say i would i probably
wouldn't assault that person
they had something called
that they called organized quality
so the person just looks organized
and what's funny is that from a
leadership perspective
if you look squared away
it's a real thing
if you look squared away people
sense that
the victims the way most of the people
that were identified as oh i would
attack that person
they would say they had inconsistency in
the way they walked so there's something
disheveled about them
so
that's
another thing that this is just another
indicator that this is a real thing
the way we carry ourselves the body
language that we have
down to the way that we walk
this isn't like you and i are in a
conversation and you're crossing your
arms this is just the way that you were
walking around it's existing yeah it's
just the way you're existing so
how are we so so how should we walk
how should we carry ourselves so there's
i found another article i started diving
into this uh
into this rabbit hole a little bit nbc
news had an article written by
steve cardian who was a police officer
he's in the marine corps
he's a detective he's a fbi defensive
tactics instructor actually i'm not sure
if he's in the marine corps not but
the crux of this article
is that it takes a criminal
about seven seconds to decide whether
you're a good victim or a bad victim
and so again there's a there's a
psychological study that he cites in
here
uh betty grayson and morris stein where
violent criminals rated
videos of pedestrians from one to ten
and one uh
from easy to victimize two i would avoid
trying to victimize that person
there's a couple notes here that one was
that they were there wasn't universal
filing findings
it wasn't universal and what's
interesting about that is
it wasn't universal meaning that someone
that you might think would obviously
make a good victim not all of them would
select it so for instance
if you had a
older
very small like a petite older woman it
wasn't like necessarily universal oh
that's an easy target which is
interesting right yeah you wouldn't
think that
you'd think oh small older woman that's
an easy target
not universal
they're judging on
how they carry themselves how they
actually walk down the street
affects their judgment
so how are we supposed to walk
what are the things that you're supposed
to be doing so
one of them is stride length
forceful dynamic steps
forceful dynamic steps medium length
so you're not trying to like step too
far because then you then you look
awkward which we're not if you look
awkward you're a victim yeah okay you're
just trying to look
kind of effortless the more effortlessly
someone walks the less chance of being a
victim now
think about this from a leadership
perspective
the way you walk into a meeting
right there's a little thing here you
start thinking about it how you walk
into that meeting are you walking with
forceful dynamic steps hey i'm in here i
know where i'm going
details feet move in a fluid graceful
motion
arms
slightly bent
natural swing
they have to oppose the leg movement
obviously
right so we're not doing
some weird yeah some robots
walking lunges
weight shift balance is smooth and the
and the speed
here's another good point the speed
do you think you should walk faster than
everybody else or slower than everyone
else or the same as everybody else i
feel like the same because yeah because
like that's how you know like i'm just
doing the doing what i'm supposed to be
doing yep you you are correct
with the caveat of the same or just a
little bit faster just a little bit
faster
posture
you know you got to stand up straight
make sense
um stand up straight put your shoulders
back i guess we can we can say
jordan peterson chiming in
so that's what it is that's how you're
supposed to walk here's how you don't
walk you don't take big giant steps
because you look clumsy that means if
you're taking big giant steps it means
your reach are kind of your feet are
kind of stretching out you're you're
trying to go and people notice that
you don't want to take little small
steps either little tiny steps
because then you either look timid or
you look like you're hurt or like you're
limping and you're like a weak gazelle
out out on the planes that's about to
get taken down
you can't swing your arms too much
[Music]
it's funny because like these are all
everyday things right everybody arms
band
when they like basically outline the
actual
um with the characteristics it's like
you can't swing your arms too much you
imagine a guy like swinging his arms
crazy but it's
what i like about these things is it's
kind of things like you said you don't
even notice it yeah so what if you're a
person that does these things yeah or
when you get nervous you do something
yeah you need to pay attention to it and
there's a difference between um
like and i'm not sure how these cycle
guys
how they evaluated it but were they just
super in tune with it or were they like
consciously like oh i see his steps are
a little bit small or that girl's steps
is kind of small let me you know
victimize her whatever or or like i said
like they just sort of feel it you know
and then maybe it took some expert to
kind of break it down yeah i i i agree
with you i bet there's people that go
i'd i'd go after that person and then
you have to go why yeah well they look
look how look how small they're walking
or look how small their steps are look
at their their arms are that was another
one if your arm swing is too small that
means you're timid yeah which you can
imagine someone walking all huddled up
right together
um
small arm swing
indicates
low energy low e low energy easy target
uh jerky body when you when your body's
like
off balance it means you're
uncoordinated again easy target
yeah if you're slumped over you're
hunched it means you're scared
if you're sl if you're slower than
everybody else you're probably injured
you're probably some way weak you can't
propel yourself with any amount of force
yeah
you for sure can't get away that's kind
of like what it feels like you know they
can't they can't escape look how slow
this guy is so that's what we're not
doing right that's not what we're not
doing we're not walking like that
and then on top of these things of more
things to do is be looking around
right you shouldn't be just obviously
what do we see nowadays all the time
people staring at their phone you should
have your what we used to call on the
seal team's head on a swivel you know
looking around
looking at people yeah yeah i see you
i'm tracking you you don't have to stare
at them but you just look at them you
know maybe you give them a little nod
but you at least let them know i'm
tracking you yeah i see what you're
doing
let them know that you see them and then
that thereby takes away the element of
surprise it puts them in a little
discomfort
there was a thing on uh
like criminals like burglaries and and
one of the the factors was neighborhood
watch
so neighborhood watch is like you know
typically we know what that is right
typically it basically means that like
we're watching right that we're not you
know we're not all armed necessarily but
we're watching and the crimina the i
think is a video maybe some documentary
i don't know either way the criminal
people these were guys in jail that that
they exposed the information right how
they cased places and neighborhoods and
all this stuff there were all this
criteria but neighborhood watch was the
number one thing that they would avoid
because people are just like looking
that's it where were dogs on there
i always thought dogs were the number
one thing yeah so i vaguely remember a
dog thing and i if i remember correctly
it would depend
but i don't i don't know i can't speak
on the dog thing
there's no one in their right mind that
would try and get into my house with my
dog oh yeah well no not your dog but i
guess when you when you say dog it's
like okay what kind of dog you know i
get it like dogs will bark or whatever
but the thing is dogs bark all the time
yeah so it depends on the dog what if
it's like a little one of these little i
don't know what poodles i don't know all
the dog types but you know the little
ones that sort of may or may not bark
maybe whatever but we know it's going to
be a pain
right if i'm breaking into that house i
know at a minimum i've got a freaking
barking dog that's drawing attention to
this situation i feel like
more accurately it at the very least
it's unpredictable it's way less
predictable at the very least but no at
least even less than that is it's
freaking barking right now and drawing
attention to the situation that i'm
causing yeah if they bar you know like
some dogs they straight up just don't
bark dude my dog when my my dog scares
me
when i'm in the house yeah like when i'm
in the house and he'll go on alert for
something and bark it's it you know i
get a little bit of a oh yeah but again
you're talking about your dog like your
dog scares me too okay so the okay so
i'll tell you a little story um and this
actually kind of makes it like more
clear okay so
i went to
okay i had a friend his name's blake
malin i used to film with him and i went
to his house for the first time
up in l.a or you know where he lived and
he wasn't home yet so he was like hey
just just go inside or whatever he
didn't say he had a dog oh damn he's
like yeah just go inside so i'm like oh
okay cool
i'll just go inside i guess so i go
inside i have my camera or whatever so i
go inside and i'm inside the house and
here comes this freaking dog out of the
next room
the thing wasn't barking it was huge too
huge dog like it wasn't a great dane
but i'll show you a picture of him he's
like it's not the dog you want in there
when you just roll into someone's house
and
he wasn't he wasn't barking he wasn't
eyes all big he wasn't he didn't run up
he just slowly walked as if he knew i
was supposed to be there like blake told
him i was coming or something like that
and he came and i was scared i'm gonna
be honest like i wasn't
i wasn't very confident at that moment
so i like slowly like
went back in my car straight up left the
house went back in in the car and he
came out with me so i called blake i was
like hey
your dog's here he's like oh yeah he's
not going to do nothing but i heard that
before you know that whole thing oh he's
not going to do nothing meanwhile he's
like trying to eat you or whatever so
i'm like all right and then so i kind of
slowly got out and he wasn't wagging his
tail nothing but the the point is he
wasn't barking he didn't make no noise
i'd never been there before he'd never
met me nothing like this dog isn't a
very good deterrent no he's not and
that's what i'm saying even though he
actually kind of was he deterred you oh
yeah his whole appearance did but what
if his appearance didn't what if it was
a little poodle i'm a robber yeah i go
in the house and a little poodle slowly
just rolls in kind of like a different
story you must be blake's friend if you
have a pathetic dog that's a poodle a
small poodle that doesn't bark yep
you're crazy that's not a good deterrent
no it is not you you're applying this
yeah like how many people have crazy
dogs dogs bark
yeah most dogs bark bro
that's like most humans
they think like there are humans that
can't speak for whatever that seems like
it's correct it seems like it's correct
because all the dogs that i've ever had
i don't care if it's like a delivery i
don't care if it's i don't care if it's
like someone who's on their way that
they met before they're barking yeah
they see somebody exactly that's in my
experience too but i haven't met all
dogs i haven't met all people i you know
so i don't know but we can agree that
every dog you've ever experienced except
for one bark
no man i don't know i don't know i i
probably could think of other dogs that
don't bark actually
no your dog pretty much parked at me
every single day
not at me but all right i heard them
so
we know that it's a deterrent
and just look at this
head on a swivel look at people it's a
deterrent much like a barking dog if you
don't have one if you have a dog that
barks which you probably do
that's a deterrent and also looking at
people which is here's the counter
intuitive thing about looking at people
sometimes people don't want to look at
you because they're afraid you're going
to start something yeah yeah whereas
just looking at people like looking
around
is what you should be doing and when
you're not confident enough to look at
someone that's a signal in its own right
so if you're not looking at me i know
you're not confident yeah right that's a
very common thing yeah we're like when
you know when you look
and like they look in then they look
down like oh as if to say oh i wasn't
looking at you i wasn't looking at you
don't do that look and then look back
ahead look forward yeah
head on a swivel um
so okay so
what we just talked about is how we want
to present ourselves
as far as appearing as a
not pray we don't want to appear as prey
so that's what we need to do